so you can either be in tokyo going to
you know the craziest omakase of sushi
or you come to burger omakase i picked
the burger omakasi all day
when it comes to knowing about
restaurants and good food around the
world comedian and now cookbook author
eric werheim is a walking encyclopedia
so what impresses jaime these days i had
to switch it up on him and do something
special to back me up i brought my sous
chef christian along for the ride
behold the burger omakasi tasting menu a
chef's choice of three burgers that
represent three different eras in
hamburger history let the voyage begin
welcome burger show and welcome to our
guest eric wareheim what's up today
it's bistro della burger you're gonna be
our guinea pig i love it this is gonna
be like a burger tasting menu
beautiful i haven't eaten in four days
so i'm ready to go hard bring the
burgers inside and experience anything
you got if you were to describe your
burger palette yes
what would it be
right now
you know i started i grew up in
philadelphia okay big you know bar
burgers and i moved to la
and i got into the smash burger scene oh
yeah like your instagram literally is
like my like map yes i have to know
where you eat like i don't i no longer
look at
food blogs i just look at your instagram
because you wherever you're eating has
to be it is well i also i i i call it
top food blog and i did it as a joke
back you know when i started i was like
i'm not doing comedy anymore i'm just
doing burgers pizza sushi i love that
now i'm like i'm into it and you used to
have food clubs yeah what what's that
about food club was a show uh we made
one episode on youtube this is a big
moment for food club uh we're about to
plaque son of a gun this is what it's
all about we eat somewhere really enjoy
it and we present them with this plaque
and it was kind of like
10 years ago when the michelin star
system people were kind of like hating
on it being like [ __ ] this these rules
yeah so we would roll in with like
skipper hats on and suits and pretend
that we would rate these restaurants as
amateurs but we would make little
plaques that being said we have
something special for you
all right i got my man right here
wow
voila there we go i'm gonna be very
honest now that i have my captain's hat
so this is our first burger and this is
not your traditional burger we're going
way back in time we're going i mean
you're a history buff yeah we're going
back to the port side town of hamburg
wow in germany
what he said watch the mic
uh this is romantic okay
water sugar
thank you sir appreciate it this is a
2021 tap i appreciate it
feels right it just feels good thank you
this is
burger 1.0 no bun wow yeah this is way
before it was a handheld thing yeah no
frills
chuck
we have our beef gravy hot
wow
boom we got that nice my yard we're
gonna grab a little bit more of this
tala this tallow
this is the secret to so many things
right yeah i mean don't throw your fat
away
and then i have potatoes right here some
onions i love how you're starting me
with this this seems like this would be
the grand finale of the dish but
yeah we'll get this nice and crispy they
have one more ingredient to this can you
check the microwave for me christian
chef mike
this is smelling boom
so tell us about this
wow okay this is uh food heim
are you just gonna hold it for me here i
love that
um this is foodheim this is uh it's a
culinary adventure it's my brand new
book
it's it's it's the only book that you
need you can throw away all your
cookbooks except for alvin it's just
insane i mean look at this to open up to
any page fun fun
you know what i'm saying how appropriate
that's why i think we're connected we
understand the portability it's also
like oh here's a schnitzel what's this
thing i hear about a tiny horse there is
a small horse chapter okay it's very
controversial on the first page i just
mentioned small horses are for petting
not for eating and that's a very simple
philosophy i know around the world
people have eaten horse meat i have
tried it the food heim is just anything
i i love and i love small horses so it's
in the book it makes sense
i mean look
we could eat a lot of things let's just
not eat small horses
oh i laughed so hard at your joke that i
put out the candle oh i got a guy for
that
christian
and then we're gonna grab this burger
wow just like that oh wow gravy
that is gooey gooey
heaven right there
then christian please finish it off
she is
wow number one
the hamburg steak let me dive into this
wow it's beautiful
the gravy is i'm almost mostly excited
for this
he's so gravy
[Music]
he's just giggling
listen that is so good it really does
kind of like remind you of the salisbury
steak it does and i've had those frozen
dinners i've been i've been i was in
college once totally i mean but this is
like
gorgeous man yeah i mean the burger
comes from humble beginnings it's a very
important moment in hamburger history i
like that i also think that the same
with wine is like you need to know
the classic the traditions yes before
you start doing modern stuff and this is
i agree
this is pre-bun
christian doggie bag please
i appreciate you
we're now settled into america
and the burger like we were saying has
to become handheld in the early 1900s
someone put that burger in between two
buns when i think of the perfect burger
i'm thinking smash burgers and also if
you think about it like old school
burger joints they smash burgers yeah
what do you like about smash brothers
what i like about smash burgers is
obviously that beautiful mayar thank you
christian appreciate it top you off i
could get next time if i could get this
maybe 20 degrees cooler oh okay so i
don't want to talk about it on camera
but so i'm going with it right now but
in the future christian
get it cold
what i was gonna answer about the smash
burger is all the components gonna be
perfect you need that squishy you need
that super crisp thank you christian
and then you need that unctuous
soundness of a saucer
it's like all those this was three
ounces
yeah
smashing some birds
i like to smash
like them a little further on the edges
oh
that's naughty
it's gonna get that lace yes exactly
what you're doing is what i like the
thinner the better the really really
crisp on that that beef laces
yeah this is my version of the classic
drive-in burger all right
and then we're gonna hit it with some
cheese
hit you with some ketchup so what do you
think about the omakase tasting menu
format so far so far i'm loving it
because i love going my dining
experience we just come and sit down you
don't have to make any decisions
um i'm excited intrigued i don't know
what's coming up next but you have to
trust your chef i trust you guys so so
far so good i even brought out the
tweezers for you bro that's cool it's a
sign of respect i'm like i'm itching i'm
my my food blogger and he's itching to
get my phone i'm just like oh i need to
remember this as a chef i have to
suggest that you eat this this part
first okay because that's where all the
crispies are first
i don't know have you ever has this guy
seen this this is insane
i mean how classic is that
you can either be in tokyo going to you
know the craziest omakase of sushi or
you come to burger omakase i picked the
burger kazoo all day
what are we thinking what are the
emotions happening right now
i'm going to cry
i mean you want to get that crisp it's
juicy but it's not like a gusher oh i
gotta go back in
oh lordly perfect
you ready for the third burger
no i still need to work on this let's
let it
finish just hit you with nostalgia now
we're gonna hit
the modern
chef's kiss
the new stuff food blogger chef boyardee
burger so wow check that out
a5 miyazaki bms 11 jesus which means i
don't even know those numbers yeah the
first two things you said but now i
don't know what yeah bms is like the
marbling number wow 11 or 12 is the
highest
and this is 11. it's like mostly fat
it's so gorgeous i'm trying to expand
our burger horizons here so what i have
here is
finely finely chopped a5
this is luxurious
this is like
the first time i've ever seen this what
would this burger cost if this was at
this a la carte this is about 135 a
pound
and this is about a half a pound talk
about 70.
this would cost us about 210 bucks at a
restaurant amazing so i got hokkaido
milk bread here
wow that we've
uh lightly toasted with beef butter i'm
adding a little smoked shoyu aioli
so this is like high-end ingredient from
japan we fish scale
with tsukemono pickles
quick pickled cucumbers nice
little acid there acid luxurious sesame
some crunch
i like it that looks insane
oh my god i'm gonna put this on top of
the tsukemono razor blade cut fried
garlic scallions you are our vip guest
you are
we're doing everything suanye which
means
specifically perfect for you the vip we
will take notes
on your likes or dislikes what you
didn't finish what you finished i love
that i love that service that's pretty
special you come back and you're like oh
we're not gonna give you shiraku today
because we know that you don't like cod
jizz exactly thank you exactly yeah
exactly exactly christian's like
i'll take it what do you say so we're
gonna live wow
and then i'm gonna cut this
this is insane
i can't believe i got to eat this so
there you go wow i'm gonna let you just
all right eat that get in your elements
so burgers are already from one of my
favorite things in the world you know
that we all know that that's why we're
here that's why it's called a burger
show a5
one of the most insane things ever had
japan in general the coolest place in
the world so that's what you that's
about what i'm feeling right now okay
put all those things into one also
texture i don't have to eat this to know
how much i love it i'm just gonna look
at it
i'm gonna eat it it's one good
what are we thinking
tell us the emotion okay
it's like so it's so rich and flavorful
oh my god
that's really good i also love how you
only kind of griddled one side of the
milk bread yeah because you have to have
the texture yeah when i saw you put the
cucumbers and i was like
chef that's a lot of cucumbers but you
need that because it's so rich so rich
if you don't have that layer of like
pickled crunchiness there's so much
flavor going on but it's not like i
think it's still
the beef is the star of the show
obviously so
thank you guys i'm like i'm so glad we
got to do this for you because i did i i
do know you are a true lover of food so
we wanted to show you our love
by making you a burger journey just like
this make sure to buy his book
check it out let's go burger show baby
burger show
burger show baby
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy alvin
kylon of the burger show make sure you
like subscribe and hit that notification
bell
if not for me
for the burgers